大家好，欢迎来到课堂。再次欢迎。我叫戴维·布朗，这将是一堂独创的阅读、写作和语法综合课。我很高兴大家都在这里。请各位就座。欢迎。
嘿，赫克托 (Hèkètuō)。你好吗？
我很好。您呢？
我非常好。谢谢。
欢迎。欢迎。
谢谢。
我看到您选择了一节关于论证的课。您想在今天的课上学习如何更具说服力吗？
我想学。实际上我非常想学，因为当你说另一种语言时，这是一件非常重要的事情。
是的，这个问题的基本点是：我们想要什么，以及我们如何得到它？而沟通是我们获得我们想要的东西的手段。
所以学习如何具有说服力确实是一项非常棒的软技能。
并且有一些我们可以遵循的程序来有效地进行说服。所以在今天的课上，我们将讨论有效地进行说服，以及一些可以帮助我们进行正式说服的语法、阅读和写作任务。
我们有这个“cohesion”（连贯性 liánguànxìng）的概念，连贯性是指某事物是完整的。
为了做出一个好的论证，我们需要具备论证的所有部分。
而且我们还需要论证流畅。它必须有条理。所以我们有“cohesion”（连贯性）和“flow”（流畅性 liúchàngxìng）这两个概念，我们今天会稍微讨论一下。
那么，让我们探讨一下如何实现这一点。
屏幕上有一张图片。上面写着“从杂乱无章的想法到清晰有说服力的观点”。
我们看到这个人的房间很乱。
那里的窗帘破了。
而它让那里看起来很干净。
实际上看起来像我的房间。
好的，好的。
我们的论点就像这样，对吧？
我们的论点可能杂乱无章，也可能条理清晰。
如果我们的论点以有条理的方式呈现，那么我们就更有可能说服人们相信某事是真的。
我们希望真诚地做到这一点。我们如何才能真诚地组织我们的想法，以提出一个有说服力的观点呢？
让我们看看你是否能记起一些关于论证的知识，或者告诉我你认为你对说服了解多少。
你记得论证的哪两个部分？
记得任何具体的部分吗？
实际上，我记不起来了。
你知道，比如条理清晰之类的。
让我想想另一个。
你说过，条理清晰。
和杂乱无章。
好的。
相反的就是条理清晰，对吧？
所以是条理清晰对比杂乱无章。
论证的结构怎么样？
你如何有效地进行论证？
为了做出一个好的论证，你需要做些什么？
嗯，实际上，我需要，我需要让它非常全面。
对吧？对于那个人来说。
听一个论点。对吧？
而且它必须容易。
理解。
而且也容易理解。
同意。
所以如果我们改进一些语法的方面，比如连贯性和流畅性，我们就能让它更容易理解。
我们可以让它条理清晰，而不是杂乱无章。
我们可以让它完整。我们可以让它全面。
这些是我们今天课程的学习目标。
你能为我们读一下第一个目标吗？
是的，今天的学习目标。
分析一个范例论证的结构和流畅性。
您要我把它们都读完吗？
好的。
利用图形组织工具来构建论点。
理解语法选择如何影响清晰度。
和连贯性。
练习有效地使用过渡词语。
并识别和纠正影响论证清晰度的常见错误。
好的，让我们练习一下这里的这两个词。
这个词发音是，跟我读，clarity, clarity。
哦，clarity。
好的。
这个词带有 Jen 的音，像 Z 一样。
有点像 ZJ 的音，cohesion。
Cohesion 和 clarity。
好的。
是的，我没注意到它是。
和 clear 一样的词。
我实际上搞混了。
是的，它和 clear 这个词有关。
所以 clear。
是的，它们相关。
是同一个东西。
对。
我是这么想的。
嗯哼。
所以你有 clarity 这个名词，而某物是 clear 的，
那是形容词。
是的。
好的。
那么我们首先可以从论证的剖析开始。
论证的不同组成部分。
这是我们可以学习的东西。
并且回想一下在学校写论文之类的日子。
你如何构建一篇论文？
写作时，什么先来，什么其次，什么最后？
让我们读一下这部分。
你能为我读一下这段吗？
当然。
一个精心构建的论证类似于一个精心设计的结构。
它需要坚实的组成部分和无缝的连接。
连贯性确保思想在逻辑上相互关联。
而流畅性则让读者能够顺畅地理解论证。
好的，非常好。
所以我做了这张图片来用几何方式展示这个想法。
所以我们有这样一个想法：论证是完整的。
但是一个论证可以是完整的，但却不流畅。
一个论证可以包含所有部分，但它们没有很好地组合在一起。
所以如果我们看这个的每个阶段，我们会发现它开始于一些没有很好连接的元素。
它们没有通过我们需要的推理连接起来。
我们看到它开始形成，但没有很好的流畅性。
当流畅性得到改善时，我们最终得到一个完美的圆。
所以这阐释了连贯性的概念，也就是它的完整性。
这张图片中的六边形具有连贯性，但没有流畅性。
而这个圆，则既有连贯性又有流畅性。
那么我们怎样才能做到呢？
我们如何构建我们的段落和论文？
使其有条理，包含所有需要的部分。
并且使其从一部分到下一部分过渡合乎逻辑。
如果我们做得对，如果我们做得有效，那么我们就同时拥有了这两个元素，并加强了我们的论证。
所以我们有这些论证元素，即拼图的各个部分；连贯性，即连接结构；以及流畅性，即思想之间的顺畅流动。
好的。所以我们需要记住论证的这些核心组成部分。
让我们读一下这些。你能为我读一下吗？
当然。我可以从最开始读吗？
比如回顾论证的核心组成部分：主张 (claim)，事实 (facts)，背景 (background)，论点 (thesis)，
主题句 (topic sentences)，证据 (evidence)，例子 (examples)，潜在的反驳 (potential rebuttal)，
和结论 (conclusion)。对这些元素的扎实掌握是基础。
非常好。
所以我们有“claim”（主张）。“claim”的另一个说法是“thesis”（论点）。
我们有“background”（背景），也就是我们谈论内容的上下文。
如果我们开始谈论并开始论证，但没有人知道我们谈论的是什么，它的背景是什么，那么它就不清晰。
所以我们从“claim”（主张）开始。
我们可以提供一些关于它的背景信息。
然后我们有我们的“thesis statement”（中心论点陈述）。
这是一个中心论点陈述，基本上是我们试图说服对方相信的整个事情的主要论点。
所以说服就是让别人相信某事。